Today’s 1 Minute Monday is
Don't Ask for Permission.
If you’ve got a great idea that you want to try out
something that you know
is going to really help your customers
go and do it and don’t ask for their permission
because usually what happens is
if it’s something new
if it’s something that hasn’t been tried before
then they’re scared and they’re skeptical
and they’re going to say no a lot of the times
when you know that it’s something
that’s going to help them.
And I recently made this mistake
with one of my clients.
I had this great new idea
that I knew would help them
I knew would help them accomplish their goals
but they’ve never done it before
and so they’re scared
and they’re worried and they said
“May not now, maybe in a few months
maybe we could figure something out.”
I’m like, “Aaahhhh! I didn’t listen to my own rule!
Because I know I could’ve helped them.”
And now if I go and do it
then I’m going against them, right?
They told me not to do it
so I can’t go and do it now.
But if I didn’t ask for their permission
the worst thing that would happen is
I’d have to beg for their forgiveness
and usually people are pretty cool with that.
But, ugh, you got an idea
you know it’s going to work for your client
don’t’ ask for permission
just go and do it for them!
Believe.